your body your psyche your relationships
your business your competitors it
doesn't matter what it is every once in
a while you need to shock everybody you
see if you think about all of them we
have a routine every once in a while and
what I mean by routine is there is a
positive thing about it Ruth you got to
come to work every single they got a
workout you got to have you know time
with your family go do all those things
but every once in a while you need to
show something that no one is expecting
let me explain
if you think about working on Monday is
the national chess day everybody at the
gym on Monday this chest it's just how
it is Valentine's Day everybody goes on
a date Christmas is family time and all
these things just you know when it comes
out to November December sale time
everybody's got to have a better sell
all that is great you got a shot come on
no one's expecting you you got a shot
your girl when she's not expecting to
get a flowers
you got to shock your family when no
one's expecting anything you got to put
something together surprises everybody
you got to shock your competitors when
they least expect it with an
announcement that they said what is this
come from you got a shock every body
your body you got to change the routine
don't start off with just on Mondays you
just on Friday you know typically you do
back in triceps don't do back in try to
do chest and biceps completely mix it up
you start off with bench press blast
bench press start off with flight you've
got a shock everything and if this
routine doesn't get shocked it stays
flat or it never explode so it depends
if you want an exponential growth every
once in a while in every aspect of your
life you got a shot every aspect of your
life in one way or another before it
becomes a routine and everyone gets
bored most important you get any bored
and if you get bored what the hell are
you pushing for you need a bit of spice
to be a little bit spontaneous and all
those areas of your life
[Music]